Pour la première fois, on voit
la persécution et la répression
brutale de la minorité musulmane
Ouïghours de l'intérieur même
du système étatique secret
chinois. Des milliers de
portraits de femmes, d'hommes
et même d'adolescents de 15 ans,
pris après leur arrestation.
Des photos d'exercices anti-
émeutes dans les camps
d'internement au cours desquels
on donne l'instruction aux
gardiens de tirer pour tuer
s'il y a tentative d'évasion.
Ce qu'on appelle les Xinjiang
Police Files; ces milliers
de documents piratés dans les
serveurs de la police chinoise
et publiés par un és par un és m
de 14 médias, c'est le chercheur
Adrian Zenz qui les a obtenus.
Les documents et transcriptions
de conversations démontrent même
que le président chinois,
Xi Jinping, est personnellement
impliqué dans le s
répressif.
MARIE LAMENSCH
- C'est justement cet amas
de preuves, d'instructions
et d'une volonté, justement, de
nuire à la population ouighoure,
qui démontre qu'on devrait
vraiment s'inquiéter et qu'on a
ici à faire probablement
à un génocide.nocide.nocide.noc.
- Les révélations sur la
répression des Ouighours sont
publiées au moment où la haute-
commissaire des Nations Unies
aux droits de l'homme, Michelle
Bachelet, entame une visite dans
le Xinjiang.
Une tournée encadrée, sous haute
surveillance, dansance, dansance
sanitaire anti-COVID et dans
des lieux précis, pré-
déterminés. Aucun journaliste
n'y a accès et il n'y aura aucun
ire après la visite.
Le gouvernement chinois qualifie
les Xinjiang Police Files
de rumeurs et de mensonges.
L'oeuvre des États-Unis, de la
Grande-Bretagne et d'autres pays
occidentaux visant à saboter
la visite de Michelle Bachelet.
Bon nombre de défenseurs des
droits de la personne craignent
plutôt ite serve
à la propagande chinoise.
- C'était de démontrer
finalement que cette visite
n'amènera aucune vérité et
ce qu'il faut regarder c'est
justement ces nouveaux documents
auxquels on a accès aujourd'hui.
- Les révélations sur le
Xinjiang suscitent de nouveaux
appels aux sanctions contre
les hauts dirigeants du parti
communiste chinois.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Tor